la parole est maintenant notre collègue
alain vasselle pour le groupe hn est
républicain merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
interpelle en qualité de chef du
gouvernement le gouvernement il ne se
passe pas de jour une annonce une
réforme la réforme du prélèvement de la
source à la la source à l'impôt sur le
revenu une réforme du code du travail
faire voter le tiers payant la mise en
oeuvre de la révision des bases de la
valeur locative et veut faire voter la
réforme de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement pour les collectivités
toutes ces réformes ont un point commun
monsieur le ministre le gouvernement a
décidé qu'elle n'entrerait en vigueur
qu'après 2010 est en vertu de quelle
logique
monsieur le premier ministre
reportez-vous systématiquement tout en
affirmant quotidiennement qu'il ya
urgence absolue à réformer le pays
nous attendons votre réponse pour
répondre alain vasselle la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
il y à là au sénat mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le président une
ambiance que j'aime désormais retrouver
régulièrement et est une attente
je ne trouve pas ailleurs mais que je
vois ici monsieur alain vasselle jeu
pourrait rappeler dans bien des domaines
les différentes réformes que nous avons
menée même s'il faut souvent se mettre
d'accord sur le mot réforme qui parfois
d'ailleurs inquiète nos concitoyens si
on ne donne pas un sens au mot réforme
c'est-à-dire la modernisation du pays
mais aussi la justice sociale qui
s'imposent mais il y en a de nombreuses
je pense bien sûr au mariage pour tous
je pense à la diminution du nombre de
régions je pense à la réforme du collège
je pense à la parité je pense au non
cumul des mandats qui a trouvé un succès
certain dans cette assemblée
je pense à la mise en oeuvre de la
banque publique d'investissement
j'arrête là parce qu'il s'agit de
réformes menées depuis 2012 et qui sont
nombreuses
je pense à l'engagement qui le plus
important de mon point de vue qui est
bien sûr la réforme profonde de notre
économie par et la baisse du coût du
travail la fiscalité sur les entreprises
40 milliards d'euros mais qui
s'accompagne et c'est nécessaire par la
lutte indispensable contre les déficits
publics 50 milliards d'euros sur trois
ans puisque il s'agit de redonner de la
force et de la compétitivité à notre
pays mais vous m'interrogez sur les
réformes à venir il y en a trois
importantes
je ne serai pas long je veux uniquement
les évoquer celle concernant le droit du
travail
personne n'a jamais remis sur le métier
cette réforme est essentielle pour faire
qu'on sorte que la négociation entre les
salariés et les responsables des
entreprises se fasse au plus près du
terrain dans les entreprises ou dans les
branches branche qu'il faut par ailleurs
diminué nous allons réécrire en moins de
deux mois
c'est la mission que nous avons confié à
robert badinter en moins de deux mois
l'ensemble des principes prescripteurs
par ailleurs pour ce qui concerne
le droit du travail et des textes de
lois de 2016 nous allons nous attaquer à
l'organisation du temps du travail parce
que chacun sait qu'aujourd'hui elle est
trop rigide et qu'à l'époque du
numérique il faut être capable de faire
démonstration de souplesse 120 ou 130
pages du code du travail qui concerne
l'organisation du travail sont d'ores et
déjà modifié en 2016 et puis enfin parce
que le code du travail
c'est une oeuvre particulièrement
importante peut-être faudra-t-il aller
plus vite sur tel ou tel aspect nous le
nom du temps et je pense et je réponds
d'une certaine manière à votre marque
qu'il faut aussi se donner du temps et
le fait de le faire y compris sur deux
ans et qui enjambe un quinquennat c'est
me semble-t-il dans une république
moderne dans un pays moderne capacité de
réformer qui doit permettre à chacun de
converger vers une réforme qui est
importante et qui doit associer bien sûr
le patronat les organisations syndicales
et la représentation nationale puisque
elle sera consultée sur ce sujet là mais
ces deux réformes
elle se fera elle est engagée il y à des
textes de loi important celui qui vient
bientôt sur le numérique et la loi sur
les nouvelles opportunités économiques
et là également et c'est un message
d'optimisme qu'il faut être capable
aussi de faire passer dans la société
les opportunités offertes par le
numérique ce que ça représente comme
changements sur le marché du travail
dans l'entreprise mais aussi dans la vie
quotidienne dans l'organisation du
travail donc pour les services pour les
entreprises pour l'état ces réformes
seront aussi importantes elles elles
seront adoptées en 2016 et puis elle
réformes importantes sur les questions
d'égalité à travers tous les
problématiques du logement de la
citoyenneté de la jeunesse qui
accompagne ce que nous avons engagées
notamment en matière d'école de mixité
sociale dans les collèges la ministre à
s'exprimer dans un instant répondant à
l'une de vos questions et celle réforme
fera l'objet aussi celles concernant
l'égalité et la citoyenneté parce que
modernité autorité sécurité égalité sont
les axes importants de la politique que
nous menons un ce qui concerne enfin la
fiscalité
monsieur le sénateur mais enfin tout le
monde évoque depuis des années tout le
monde la demande
la retenue à la source et tout le monde
disait on ne peut pas le faire parce que
c'est compliqué nous l'engageons et
cette réforme comme d'autres est
irréversible
et personne n'y reviendra et c'est
plutôt de bonnes méthodes faire en sorte
que là aussi elles se mettent en oeuvre
sur deux trois ans et qu'elle s'applique
à partir du 1er janvier 2018 personne
n'y reviendra mais chacun sait désormais
que ces deux réformes est inscrite dans
la réalité dans la réalité fiscale dans
la réalité
qu'attendent aujourd'hui nos concitoyens
sur la dgf curieuse curieuse critique
vous ne demandez l'ensemble les
associations d'élus qui peuvent être
représentées ici je salue françois baron
et nous verrons en fin d'après midi avec
une délégation de la mf pour préparer le
congrès de la semaine prochaine tout le
monde le dit il faut un peu de temps il
faut y travailler mais le gouvernement
écoute les principes sont voté dans la
loi de finances et la réforme de la dgf
qui sera conclue ce printemps prochain
avec l'ensemble des simulations
notamment sur les perspectives
pluriannuelles
elle sera appliquée à partir du 1er
janvier 2017 donc j'en conclu monsieur
le sénateur c'est que nous avons une
approche différente de la réforme pour
moi les réformes sont celles qui
s'inscrivent dans le temps et qui sont
efficaces
ça n'est pas l'esbroufé c'est une
capacité à réformer une société qui est
difficile à réformer
mais ce que nous avons engagé change et
changera profondément le pays qui a
besoin de se préparer à confronter les
grands défis de l'avenir
mais dans la justice est ce que le
demandent les français shalom un faible
pour une minute
lesieu premier ministre drôle
hasard du calendrier que d'attendre la
mi-mandat présidentiel pour engager des
réformes structurelles comme celle que
vous venez de dulcie fia la semaine
je note monsieur le premier ministre que
vous avez passé cinq minutes de votre
temps à justifier ces réformes sans
doute expliquer réellement ce qui
justifiait une mise en oeuvre aussi
tardive le constate monsieur le premier
ministre
aujourd'hui c'est le mécontentement
général dans le pays les médecins vont
être dans la rue après les avocats et
les policiers
c'est de la véritable valse-hésitation
que à laquelle nous assistons de la part
de ce gouvernement
et bien nos concitoyens seront le moment
venu tirer les enseignements de votre
position i